amber ban we're back and we're always
back we're always back yeah we we're
back a dinosaur's tail or but what is
that oh yes right yeah the not Don Bluth
movie but it was it was made by people
who are alumni of dom Bluths stable okay
yeah okay like which to remind me of Don
Bluth oh land before time's right okay
um last thing he are on the 50 movies
American tail and Fievel goes west last
movie he ever directed was titan AE Oh
interest her yeah he took us higher oh
that's right creed song the cruise huh
oh poor scott stapp the oh the Obama CIA
was after him or oh yeah the guy Danny
was homeless and now he's getting a
reality show thank you know yeah this
man has mental illness the worst thing
for him is to make him is like to demand
for him to run a reality show yeah I
mean I don't do that to a person haven't
we learned anything from depression
quest yeah cuz speaking of depression
quest it's time for what part is the
part of three I guess this would be part
3 part 3 and on of our adventure through
depression quest once again i am aaron i
am not aaron i'm gerry this time will i
be next time once mine down and last one
last we left off on depression quest um
we couldn't sleep because we were
thinking about all of our failures and
what a terrible person we were and we
were gonna go on the computer yeah we're
gonna go on the computer at like 2am
honest sunday yeah we have work in the
morning and sounded like a really great
scenario that I've been a part of me to
you many a time oh also i specially
remember times when I've been in this
scenario when I had some assignment due
the next morning oh yeah yeah much of
Colin
yeah yeah those cows I was grad school
for me that was that was my thesis I was
not a very good student when it came to
like doing [ __ ] on time or in a timely
fashion listen nobody is in college you
want it you want to get good at college
you you vie for a professor's sympathy
and get them to understand it's like oh
yeah this is really [ __ ] hard to
manage yeah it's like I'm working
several jobs at once mm-hmm and most of
them are all these [ __ ] glasses yes
then expect for me to like read tomes
between now and next week and right you
know you knew you knew that Professor
that that one at our enter alma mater
that would assign like seven seven
novels in a semester 70 this isn't
master this isn't this isn't a this
isn't that what sort of look for an
exaggeration we got assigned like what
what makes Sammy run the love of the
last tycoon of Human Bondage the red and
the black and several other works to
read in their entirety in one semester
yeah I was grew that was that was that
was a girl and look up the red and the
black and of Human Bondage because those
are those are both buildings Romans so
they're [ __ ] thick tome ass books and
like and then what there was him and
there was the other guy oh yeah if you
know the who was like that was like a
grad school level course but at some
point took two of his classes yeah and
at least one of them was like one
professor was the great white and he was
the one that had all the novels and the
other one was Megalodon and it wasn't
novels but it was just [ __ ] tons of
scholarly articles I came to learn as
you know love and hate all at the same
time Susan Sontag through this class I
thank God I was also taking a woman's
studies class in the same semester
because it was like oh here's some
horses and Sontag without me wanting to
kill myself oh hey I'm gonna have to see
two sides of the same coin yeah and then
I saw something but Susan Sontag on TV
where she had like a badass quote Adam
and I think a commencement address where
she was just like don't take [ __ ] tell
the bastards off I'm like if I ever gave
a commencement address that's how it
would want to end it in my commencement
address would this be like four words
long just walk up on stage and say don't
be updated don't bleep bull [ __ ] don't
be [ __ ] I'm gonna I'm gonna start us
off with some mood music as we dive back
into this listen zoe quinn ass adventure
through the psyche um zq last time
around we were going with borin inter
club of gore um that was a sunset
mission this is borin andrew club of
gore midnight radio i feel like these
are both are more recent albums I'm not
a big club of gore dude I just you know
if I hear it it's like oh yeah this is
cool this is the German jazz jam the
German ambient jazz band i can assume
they're German I'm good cuz like wow if
you're gonna do an ambient jazz band why
would you name yourself as German ass
name unless you were yourself German hey
I guess that makes sense if that's a
reasonable line of logic yeah unless
someone's like oh man I won't really
want our music to sound like you know
you're walking around in the war film is
set in usually Los Angeles or New York
or I'm and just named everything I do
German it is a ridiculous Germany this
podcast is getting rebranded on casa
scoops the stubs that stubs Duncan osh
at that sounded legit yeah hot stoves
Duncan Irish I have no idea this is I
did not take care what does that
actually mean that feel like that
probably means something what does stop
stop Donkin harsh well because it sounds
like I know I know arsh or ours is at
least close enough to the german word
for ass yeah I was like that almost
sound like the stubs thank you ass was
that's our yeah dong dang danke danke I
assume i assume dank is not a cognate in
german yeah so this is the samee I'm
sure there's there's a cave somewhere
they had to discuss me so this is boa
and andrew club of gore midnight radio
oh yeah that radios so midnight so jump
back in picking up it's late um after we
left all just to just explain away that
yawn I'm not trying to be rude to you
the viewers listeners you can try way
harder to be rude if you want to oh yeah
I mean rude rudeness doesn't take effort
but it does right now cuz I don't feel
like being it's 2 a.m. on a sunday and
you have work in the morning I just like
we said yeah you roll over to see the
sickly green glow of the time displayed
on your LED alarm clock and let out an
exasperated side you've been trying to
fall asleep for over three hours now to
no avail every time your head hits the
pillow you're overcome with anxious
thoughts that wrap themselves around
each other worries about your job little
worries about your future leetle worries
about your very identity and you're
unable to shake them off long enough to
doze off no your eyes won't even stay
shut as your mind races through imagine
scenarios going horribly wrong wish you
promptly attribute to your general
worthlessness your thoughts run too fast
for you to come to a satisfying
conclusion on any one of them your room
is completely silent but the silence has
given way to a loud static noise
rattling around inside your head your
heart beats loudly and you worry it's
beating a little too fast worried that
if you focus too strongly on your racing
heart you'll freak yourself out hard
enough that you have a heart attack you
have to be a wait for work in the mirror
eight hours and you know that your work
is so much worse on only a few hours
sleep what do you do the only option on
five out of six options the only option
number six go to your computer sleep is
clearly not happening no matter how long
you lay here you are depressed
interaction is exhausting and you're
becoming
or more withdrawn you're seeing a
therapist even though you doubt anything
she says could make you feel better you
are not currently taking medication for
depression I think that these other
option I think we I think we we noted
this lesson these other options are
starting to get a lot more yeah by T and
negative yeah the these options gone or
[ __ ] these yeah these these options got
more frenetic as you went down the
roster alright so we went to the
computer what hugs Bose you get out of
bed and head to your desk laying in bed
with nothing but your thoughts to keep
you company makes you feel like you're
going insane the harshness of the light
coming from the screen makes you squint
as you turn it on despite how often you
find yourself in this exact situation
there have been so many nights lately
just like this as you begin reading a
news story an online friend of yours I
am jus attic you're up late again I see
you yeah can't sleep again thinking too
much again and it corrects the word
thinking cuz it comes out misspelled you
guessed it sadface want to talk about it
you end up talking with addict for quite
some time about how you've been feeling
he's always been easy to talk to you
about personal matters and the added
security of talking online helps being
able to rethink what you say as you type
it out and check it before you send it
helps you gather your thoughts and you
find it less intimidating in a way to
type it all into a prompt and say it out
loud addict I don't want to be that guy
who thinks they can diagnose something
because i read a Wikipedia article but
it kind of sounds like you might have
depression you should talk to someone
about that like a doctor you pause are
you really that transparent or is it
that you've gotten used to talking about
your feelings at this point your
insomnia makes you a little paranoid but
you shake it up we can do some research
and see if there's a good doctor near
you it's not like you're going back to
sleep anytime soon anyway might as well
do something while you're awake happy
face option one is crossed out it's you
this is just a low night I'm normally
able to sleep and I don't have
depression but thank you for your
concern right to you reply no that's
okay or three you reply actually I have
talked to someone about it I would go
through i will go through two at that
point um let's see you are very
depressed you spend a large amount of
time sleeping hating yourself and have
very little energy or motivation you
spend some time a therapist couch you're
having difficulty finding the motivation
to continue going to your sessions you
are not currently taking medication for
depression so three boom yeah yeah [ __ ]
you added we already gone to the
therapist attic okay I'm glad you're
taking that step I've heard it's not an
easy one I know people kind of suck at
understanding this sort of stuff
sometimes but there's nothing wrong with
having depression you wouldn't be
ashamed to have bronchitis or something
so there's no reason to be ashamed if
it's in your if it's your brain that's
sick instead oh man what understanding
guy what a what an understanding guy in
a very wrote in generic way what uh what
what a stand-up guy attic must be with a
weird name you spend a few more minutes
talking with addict about your therapy
and your feelings about it he's
incredibly supportive and you're happy
to find that you have a confidant that
understands your illness and is willing
to lend an ear when you're having nights
like this why is a niqab silly uh attics
an online friend chances our attic is
somebody that has a goalie ER job or or
lives in Germany no was in Germany a
little while hate i think is probably a
german guys he's in this band yeah
addict from borin injured club of gore
he's my favorite guy he plays this slow
sax the slow sack it's a sax just filled
with gels of all the nuts come out
really slowly oh i can i can hear it and
it sounds kind of wet a little while
later you fall back into bed kitten in
tow and find it easier to drift off to
sleep even in therapy you know you're
still gonna have nights like these
sometimes it's good to know that you
have a friend who will help carry you
through them um
I read this wrong I thought you said in
your depressed you have an intern hey
where are we gonna intern is he helping
us is our depression how are we giving
him college credit boss I strewn all
your papers around so that you couldn't
get anything organized like you asked me
to so I guess we just go to the next
page it's a chilly Thursday night and
you've just gotten off work I feel this
felt like one of the longest days you
faced in recent memory even though
nothing exceptional had happened a ton
of minor things kept going wrong and
co-workers had tried your patience
throughout the day you can sort of
leaving work early but the last thing
you want to do was deal with your
insufferable boss on top of everything
else you're lost in thought on the
commute home and your feelings of
frustration both with your life in the
world around you build as you run into
mirror into minor annoyances like
someone bumping into you really hard as
they walk by by the time you get home
you're exhausted and remember that these
feelings are ones you identified as a
negative feedback loop with your
therapist these pent up feelings aren't
dying down and are eating at you you
open your front door and stare at your
apartment an overwhelming feeling of
exhaustion overcomes you and you feel
like your energy levels are low enough
that you'll likely settle into a single
activity tonight what do you do well
we're not going to shake off our bad
mood and do something fun for the rest
of the evening but we could potentially
reach out to someone close to you or
don't burden anyone with your problems
distract yourself
I've done both more of the time I reach
for three yeah yeah I mean to is quote
unquote the healthiest option supposedly
if I'm trying to beat the game in in
real life you get a lot of instances
where the person you're reaching out to
just isn't available hmm um or you know
worse and three it's like I know
distracting yourself I know I've reached
for three a lot of the time especially
when I was younger when I was a lot
younger especially when I was just
naturally because you know it's like
you're out of ur when you are when you
are not in a relationship it's it's a
heart just like that much more out of
your way to find somebody yeah to reach
out to cause like you know when you're
in relationship I mean if it's a good
one you you have in Auto you have an
automatic response for I'm having a
really tough time it was the first
person I can rely on mmm just because
you get that that continuous intimacy
with them um continue missing
contingency ah i would say number two
because as far as i remember number
three would never make you feel better
it would just kind of make time pass
yeah that's probably the wiser decision
so number to reach out to someone close
to you your head feels too noisy and you
need to trade it for some actual
conversation your therapist did say that
this was that it was important to reach
out to support to your support network
that sorry reading in an angle your
therapist did say that it was important
to reach out to your support networks do
you mind as well give it a shot who do
you call ghostbusters
I was gonna say Ghostbusters it was my
joke I'm sorry so you're not allowed to
think of ghostess we're not allowed to
think the same things we're not allowed
to think the thing that everyone was
gonna think on your co-workers Sam he's
friendly nothing could be a good
distraction that is crossed the eft I'll
to Sam Sam that uh we could call mom oh
I don't know yeah mom is bad she
unconditionally loves you even if she
doesn't always understand you I don't
know no mom I'm gonna Hicks name mom
right now probably not if we had a cool
mom hell yeah we don't have a cool mom
not in this game we do ya like she means
maybe but but yeah we could call Alex
cuz she's your girlfriend number for
Malcolm he's family and fun to talk to
is Malcolm our brother who now he was
better than me yeah Malcolm is her
brother who's doing way better than us
[ __ ] um er maybe maybe alex is the best
one because at least we're reaching out
yeah I was feeling the same thing
basically mom doesn't get it Malcolm is
just gonna kind of make us feel down and
shitty about ourself probably and I'm we
might feel we feel strain with Alex but
perhaps you know she'll be sympathetic
in this scenario I mean is Alex even
know we're going to a therapist is Alex
even know that we've been diagnosed I
don't know we haven't checked in on her
yeah for our girlfriend we haven't
talked to her in a while granted we
don't like cohabitate but Jesus yeah
maybe this will be the time how long
have we been dating Alex um like 20
pages now exactly right it's like how it
doesn't say forget I forget if it if it
established I mean we we'd already had a
lot of established routines I think so
we've gotten in some some steady go yeah
deddi do but it's also like we're
working and living on our own alex is
going to school so that makes things
like we have different lifestyle
patterns ok you know so it's like it's
not at that point of the relationship or
just like your answer to oh what am i
doing tonight it's like is always go
over to each other's place mmm so it
seems like you spend a lot of nights
separate from each other
or we do yeah so it's not like you're
not doing that thing where it's like we
don't live in the same place but we're
gonna kind of just sort of bridge that
gap all the time yeah yeah what we'll
find you know we'll see each other most
days whoa so it's hard to assess how
long we've been with Alex and if if it's
been long enough to honey a cigarette
especially with this music and yeah if I
don't smoke so bad for you I would I
would I would tell this we should vape
let's get vapes yeah let's be vape
daddies don't they have is that they
make vape juice that's not nicotine dat
also that you can have all the pleasures
of inhaling some kind of you know
flavored missed without any of the
addictive repercussions actually sounds
super enticing it's dumb but it's like
yeah listen I just want one that looks
like a cigarette you know I can live out
that fantasy of being a kool cigarette
man yeah in a safe and controlled
environment the worst thing that happens
is you get popcorn lung popcorn lung
yeah there's specific lung disease that
happens with workers in the factories
that make my boy popcorn because of
something that's added to the popcorn
and that same something it is added to
vape juice so there's a suspicion that
maybe too much vaping at some point far
down the line with consecutive vapes
could give you the same condition that's
what is popcorn lung is it deadly yeah
it's something for you this sounds
terrible yeah that sounds sad it sucks
it's like people love to inhale smoky
things I don't know what it is people
love to breathe things other than air
but apparently it's not okay for your
body no matter what your methodology is
yeah I mean I think it's yeah you know
and and and vage kind of freaked me out
because like especially the dudes with
like the space vapes that look like the
fist of a robot whoa with a giant block
book thing yeah
worth like a handful and it's got these
like various tubes and aunt essays and
stuff like that and then like basically
also see these dudes inhale and like the
amount of vapor that comes back out is
just like how much long Jiu stew you
have like like you've been exhaling this
thing for like 95 seconds like a like
there's too much off that drag it says
is becomes my understanding from my the
people i know who do vape is like a lot
of those buttons are just to adjust the
temperature and the thickness of the
smoke and things like that the smoke is
so thick though like it's cuz the real
secret just like there's smoke but
there's not much yeah it sounds like
he's due to vape they're like this just
keeps comin see Josh's gel so oh [ __ ]
we're gonna dial Alex you dial alex who
picks up after only two rings you ask if
she has time to talk and she tells you
she's just hanging around to her p jason
is actually somewhat bored phones due to
being caught up on her coursework you
try to figure out where to start with
how you're feeling and are overcome with
missing her face just her face I don't
miss any other part of you if you could
be like Zordon but there's didn't tube
you ask if she feels like grabbing some
dinner and you notice for barely
contained surprise and delight on the
other end of the line Oh somebody's
happy to see us oh holy [ __ ] I feel good
now hey man we probably haven't seen her
in a while that's why yeah like it's
been like 10 pages spoken yeah that was
true dinner we've been well I mean we've
been bouncing around days so maybe
there's been some elliptical visits with
Alex that just work didn't register
talking about yeah you meet about half
an hour later at an inexpensive diner
not far from your apartment while the
food is not great you're surprised by
how much your mood seems to have
elevated just being in her company well
first you were extremely hesitant to
talk about your job situation for fear
of being burdensome or sounding like a
whiner you see her listening intently to
you with what even to you seems to be
genuine concern after winding down with
a beer with a bureau the Vera you
cautiously open up a little bit
more about your feeling surrounding your
job and how drained it leaves you
feeling how you feel like you're simply
existing selling days of your life for
no real purpose you surprised even
yourself when you start talking about
how frustrated and stymie do you feel by
your job about how you used to feel
passionately about things but feel like
all your energy and capacity for
creativity it's getting leached out of
you each and every workday you can't
remember how long it's been since you've
externalized this much raw emotion I
have emotional sushi bar I have had
these these thoughts and these feelings
and I have like been on I've been into
Alex of these conversations yeah like
not not quite word for word but damn
close man yeah i'm sitting here here as
we're reading through this and I'm like
man like this is all really hidden home
you know it now this is so our lives
people made videos about this in an
[ __ ] each way yeah are you in human
like this is well I mean or you just
have never been depressed in any way
shape or form oh they probably are
extremely depressed because chances are
they're all I mean I I had to say it I
don't think anybody's gonna talk [ __ ]
about this game unless or a gamer Gator
yeah probably cuz I mean we didn't get
into the got a big detached for with
some some sort of empathy we didn't get
into the politics of it but like this
game is by zoe quinn zoe quinn was the
girl who's abusive shitty acts like
aaron gionee or whatever however you say
is in he sent the tailored a big blog
post on 4chan saying that zoe quinn
apparently slept her way into getting a
review on some website by some
journalists of this game which never
existed nobody on the website in
question ever reviewed the game and so
out of that spurred gamergate death oh i
didn't know that that was where that
came
this this is the game that started
gamergate apparently yeah really yeah
the game about feelings oh oh all right
whoo so back to zero much faith in
humanity dinner with Alex ya know you
were gonna what's next we're gonna spend
some hours the two of you spent several
hours in that diner booths long after
half-eaten food was cleared in the
waitress stop refilling your coffee cups
oh wow we're being super rude yeah as
you get the we're being super rude
hashtag Quinn spiracy hashtag gamergate
hashtag mount your shield wins spiracy
not your shield son oh no how's the
footnotes of this of this podcast this
is gonna become infinite jest with how
many detours we have to take to talk
about infinite scub the infinites do you
live in it dang the end of the dank the
end of the tank which at which of us is
dfw in which of us is the other David
you're probably dfw why I don't order
bandana no I don't either done I don't
know but I'm not a normal guy you're a
normal guy I yeah but you're I don't
know I mean like I feel like you
probably have a bit more intelligence
reading an insight under your belt so
like I'm trying I'm always trying to
scrape up to a certain level than formed
and an insightful pneus you know so I
feel like I would be the David Lipsky in
this in this iteration yeah
nah dude dfw nah do really i don't i
don't think i'm particularly like Foster
Wallace e well neither my very few
people are Foster Wallace II but thank
God thank God neither of us are Jonathan
Franzen eat yeah his name got dropped in
that movie at that point anything as you
get up to leave a sudden wave of
self-consciousness washes over you and
you suddenly feel incredibly awkward
then Alex stands up and grabs you
tightly around your waist oh damn we're
gonna [ __ ] did in this guy in this diner
we're gonna have sad sex in the diner oh
you realize that short of boring her
with your seemingly endless rants she's
simply happy to have gotten a chance to
spend time real time with you and Bill
mom it's been by all accounts of crappy
it's been by all accounts incredibly too
long since you've allowed yourself to
open up to them like this isn't alex a
girl always Alex at them now she has
become too beautiful then and there's an
almost palpable feeling of closeness you
allow yourself to hold on to as you go
to bed that night oh [ __ ] next it's an
utterly not bullet whoa yo yo take it in
the mouth daily I'm first off this page
is interesting picture of a pill bottle
at the top and the Polaroids every page
has got Polaroids of you know in the
object that's relevant to the scene so
start off with pills so I think we're
going on meds we getting this we going
on this [ __ ] did it doo doo
second all more options all options
available are blue all options are blue
I think I think things are about to turn
around we might win the game we might
beat this we might more conquer
depression we're gonna be depression and
the hills are gonna power us up yeah and
then we'll be able to replay the game
with like some special bandana that
makes us not depressed and then we can
play the dlc where we have to deal with
the
say yes who wanted to gamble with
infinite therapy session with infinite
there a few money ya know like weird
little cheese there I swear to God there
should be like depression quest to where
you have to deal with the [ __ ] side
effects of your meds and then it's like
oh no this med doesn't work and then you
have to change meds is like oh no I'm
getting withdrawals from the first meds
this one's making you too hyper and this
one's make you true slow and over the
meds that the therapist gives you don't
do anything at all it's dr. Mario dad
what is medical Tetris yeah it's an
utterly nondescript Wednesday afternoon
the type of afternoon that would
completely fade from memory unless one
made an active effort to preserve it as
has become routine on Wednesdays you're
sitting on the couch in dr. Melville's
office to your mind mild sorry to your
mild surprise she begins this session by
breaking her characteristic therapist
silence it begins speaking up right away
I was something that I always thought
was weird like why do therapy sessions
always start with the therapist being
like what's going on and then just being
quiet letting you dish because that's
you know the pre the preliminaries it's
like oh yeah let's see what's today
gonna be like do they have a lot to
offer am I gonna have to start pulling
and pressing buttons you know I wanted
to start by saying I think it's great
that you decide to come see me his head
your doctor melville voice I guess I
don't know I'm just trying to sort of
smooth it out I can't cuz I cuz I don't
want to jump to the stereotypical like a
girl yeah and you sound like Mickey
Mouse you know like I've been watching
more comedies lately where work dudes
you know play play women you know like
key and Peele sketches or other episodes
of the state and because like I think
there's only one woman in their troop
you know that we're always like multiple
[ __ ] karim
what was her name icic only think of
what her name was Trudy Weigel yeah
Trudy Weigel she was so good measure
yeah she's great on that show in fact I
want to go back and revisit renown I'm
and one now that I'm older you can
probably enjoy it more enjoy it harder
um and I never realized that was his
name junior whatever has been grant yeah
yeah it's like I never registered what
exactly he looked like without the
mustache in this Sean in the sunglasses
yeah cuz I was just associated with
writing I wanted to start by saying I
think it's great you decided to come see
me it's incredibly important first step
she begins I wanted to take some time to
do to talk to you about the possibility
of supplementing or substituting your
treatment with medication the mention of
medication makes your ears perk up and
you feel your heart rate increasing she
continues waiting keep on fighting a
farm illogical item we could actually
went to be very helpful and some who
before they take drugs completely lazy
don't need to visit a therapist at all
is my dr. Mehldau isn't as good as you
dr. Melville is like Herman Melville
like her novel was American though I'd
well I guess yeah but like I don't know
you sound like like some old British
dude on a dock you know you sound like a
guy who would be in Moby Dick all right
you you you do your or no I was enjoying
that I like really I like the doctor
Melville's a split personality alright
alright show me you prefer to take drugs
completely eliminating them d quisitor
therapist at all or providing you rely
on your support network and us too we
check out to people out before different
kept talking should you choose to start
medication so that I can monitor your
progress and adjust as needed but the
choice is ultimately your balls I just
wanted to write the option byou to gauge
what your thoughts on the matter might
be yeah dr. Melville is just giving you
a lot to think about what do you do
number one except a prescription as a
way to augment your therapy number to
tell her you'd like to try drugs instead
of therapy these weekly sessions have
always made you more than a little
uncomfortable number three the thought
of messing with your brain chemicals
makes you uneasy you'll stick with the
therapy for this whole therapy thing has
always overwhelmed you and this is the
final straw you're done with both oh boy
I'm on number one right I'm on number
one cuz like therapy feels like it's
helping a little bit here and there may
be so you know double up yeah one I feel
like that would be the most sensible is
like let's see how this goes and we'll
add a piece of it like I'm not super on
a super gun how about like oh you have
meds but like they can be helpful yeah
and there's like the experiment
everybody in this position probably you
know if it gets to that point where
someone's recommending you try you know
it's I think it's always worth the
experiment yeah and my I don't think the
game is gonna do this but wouldn't be so
wouldn't be it'd be so like [ __ ]
terrible if you like this was a game
that was like after a while there's a
plot point in the game where it turns
out your therapist actually I'm working
for you oh boy okay Oh sucks to be you
turns out you have a bad therapist you
didn't know but oh it's like yeah you're
on the message turns out in beds don't
work for you these ones give you
horrible side effects well that could be
I mean that because that seems just from
the from from from a you know basic
experience even it seems like the
likelihood of catching that is easier
because you know there are different
kinds of medications with different
active ingredients and some of them are
supposed to make you to boost your
energy some are supposed to bring you
down some we're supposed to keep you in
the middle they're all sort of different
horse therapy it's like for the most
part everyone goes to the same school
wing yeah yeah there's like an accepted
idea and there's you know techniques and
things um so number one I'm down with
the nooner oh no you think the matter
over well and hard sorry no you think
the matter over long and hard it's
strange to think that recently none of
this sort of thing was even on your
radar and here you are now being asked
to make a decision about it you're both
skeptical and nervous still getting over
the initial shock of even just talking
to a therapist still over the years
you've done enough entry level reading
on the subject to know that if it
doesn't help at least it probably won't
hurt right after an intense and
protracted period of internal
vacillation you decide to bite the
bullet and go for it you tell dr.
Melville that you'd like to try
medication in addition to your therapy
and you spend about half an hour going
over what you'll be taking and what you
should expect from it thinking back on
the decision later you're pretty sure
you had your fist tightly clenched the
whole way through number three has
changed you've started taking medication
you're hoping that it will work but you
aren't optimistic and are worried about
the side effects otherwise that is the
same um I just thought of something we
really lucked out that our therapist is
also a psychiatrist oh yeah the whole
thing that I'm going to go to somebody
else and like tell them a whole bunch of
stuff yeah it would he'll like it won't
[ __ ] suck it was like all right now
you have to go on a mission to find a
psychiatrist that is taking new patients
is available which is hard man yeah
which is hard um is in your network boy
wait a minute this is [ __ ] Canada and
in Canada everything medical works yeah
we don't have to work all man a friend
of mine just had that happen what I you
know I need some help with some stuff
started going to therapy two weeks in
there like hey we're stir the my friends
work was like hey we're gonna switch
your you're
network oh like [ __ ] a I it's another
starting over within totally new person
yeah it was like no no no we finally and
finally started probing Oh goddamn yeah
like the mental health and wellness
struggle in these United States is real
yeah just just throw this isn't one of
those [ __ ] struggles about like you
can't make a digiorno pizza yeah
straight out of Canada yeah so oh no
we're visiting our parents oh no mom
doesn't understand what means well hey
it's a wednesday evening enjoy visiting
at your parents house for a holiday it's
one of the handful of times during the
year you drive out to visit your old
home town and you've seen random people
you had gone to school with the round
town whenever bumping into them the
usual short versions of what you've done
since graduating or exchanged you've
gone through a few of these today and
have been very aware of how much you
feel you haven't accomplished
[ __ ] you're the one with the
very least left your hometown I just
like to imagine at this point in the
game like your kind of wandering around
town continent indie movie just being
like things to start the same Yuri
you're wearing a pea coat it's knowing a
little air is tousled one of those like
stumpy hats with the little tie thing on
the front um like a duck hunters hat I
like the Holden Caulfield hat yeah and I
sort of go underground to acoustic
guitar music and I wonder how many indie
movies in which someone wears a hat like
that or direct like reference to Holden
Caulfield cuz I hope it's not many it's
probably more than you want it to be
yeah they throwing out all of them more
than you wanted if you want to run for
his holding Coghill just have a dude
shoot shoot a president have you read
that book the catchment right yeah yeah
JD what do you think
who's all right all right it was like I
don't know people lose their [ __ ] over
that book and then other people hate
that book and I have yet to read that
book but it's a very divisive book I
read it when I was like I want to say 18
or 19 so i was a bit older than then the
Holden Caulfield by like just a smidge
okay so what I was so reading Catcher in
the Rye it felt like what I wanted to do
was like I remember the sense of like
wanting to reach through the pages and
grabbed it can be like I get it yes I
understand I get it but you got to get
through this yeah yes I get it sucks
everything is bad it's all terrible I
understand but you got to go through
this or else you're gonna go and say
yeah you have to you have to find a
better way to wrap your head around this
playing a game a little bit just a
little bit how long is that book gash in
the right it's a short it's a short read
for me I know some of you may know i
don't i can't stand capturing the rise
just as kid whining and just and I don't
get that because it's just like you know
yet this is very clearly an angry Kid
but we've all kind of been that angry
kid at some point hey man it's what
puberty is all about yeah being an angry
Kid and nobody understanding and [ __ ]
you mom you understand my depression
quest you gone through a few of these
today and have been very aware of how
much you feel like you haven't
accomplished when you were in high
school you had much larger plans and you
feel like you failed to manifest most of
them even if you had managed to evolve
interest in what you thought you want to
do growing up now you're not really sure
what you want to do and you felt like
you're lacking the ambition or drive to
figure it out but it's definitely not an
astronaut anymore yeah or you can't be
an astronaut or a policeman or a fireman
anymore deskjet everyone you caught up
with seems so much happier than you that
they've got their lives all figured out
and you've kind of been feeling like a
failure by comparison your brother
Malcolm arrives with his wife in tow
shortly before you all sit down to
dinner he's been traveling for his job
lately and you haven't seen him since
the day he picked you up from the
dentist your parents haven't seen him
since before then during dinner they all
catch up and Malcolm talks about the
amazing things he's done on the road
your mother turns to you and asked what
you've been up to since you've seen them
last Oh same old same old you say
nothing really new going on your mother
makes the face oh nothing new how long
are you planning on staying at that job
of yours what do you say well you don't
tell them about the exciting new job
you're getting before cuz that's not an
option to lie tell them what they want
to hear that you're actively looking for
a more prestigious position 3 admit that
you don't know what you want to do or
for excuse yourself to the bathroom
that's like an immediate thing you could
do yeah everybody's got business to do
in the bed um how long are you playing
on say that job of yours yo moms I got a
sheet yeah mom I got sure that's the
only job i care about is not [ __ ]
all over this furniture huh the
full-time job I think about it at least
twice a day if I hope it takes all the
willpower I can muster do not [ __ ] all
over your dinette set ma you don't want
[ __ ] on your dinette set it was
expensive well that's a full-time gig
right there not [ __ ] at this dinner
he was a gift from grandma who also
means well but doesn't understand you
God um that's a hard one egg yeah this
is this feels like the
I wouldn't go to that I would not I
would never go to the bathroom I don't
do that I don't ever go I've never
bathroom transcended the need to
bathroom three is more honest and that's
supposedly better for you but I that's
gonna with mom not getting it really
badly that's I can't see that going well
yes like you'll feel bad for lying but
at the same time it'll probably lead to
a it'll make more actively bummer e
conversation yeah if you if you tell mom
that you're looking for more prestigious
work that will that should said that
should say to that should please her
enough to like have a pleasant enough
dinner because like all mom is going
you're nuts about school all all mom is
gonna do is like get angry or chide you
for not having ambition and being more
like Malcolm valcom Malcomb it's like
mom you don't understand I have an
inflammation in my brain that makes it
impossible for me to be motivated or
enthusiastic about my life to
inflammation I think there's new
research that indicates that depression
is at least related to some kind of
information in the brain whoa that's
almost disturbing what I don't like your
brain too hot the difference between
chemical deficiency and and just like an
inflammation is kind of jarring it's
weird because I wonder if that's why
there's been weird um there's been weird
research for things like if you pop see
to benefit like Tylenol yeah apparently
that helps with people who have like an
existential crisis type of like habitual
mode of thinking interest yeah if people
are like wondering about what they're
going to do with their life and why are
they on this planet and everything
apparently tylenol produces that dude is
pop some tylenol ever view
that's that's the only antidepressant I
need town i'll actually know that i
think will eventually [ __ ] up your liver
no every why everything will destroy you
at some point that's why you should only
live in the woods and eat organic
vegetables unless but the organic
vegetables have will probably have
parasites on them Emmett I mean like
eating a eating of wild potato is how
the into the wild kid died really you
need a while just a bad wild potato yeah
because he didn't have he had been
living out in the wild for so long he
lost too much body fat he couldn't
really process this potato bro eat a
chicken yeah and he died and then Eddie
Vetter did this soundtrack of his movie
whiter so number two lie tell them what
they want to hear that you're actively
looking for a mower prestidigitation
position we are lying to mom yes why way
oh I'm asking for a raise soon you
mumble I'm shopping around for a better
position to G is having your cake and
eating it to us never so I'm gonna get
paid more so that I'm in a fine in i'm
in good financial straits to find my
next job yeah then i'll roll into the
next i was saying like what up B i'm
getting paid way more yeah just be like
hey can I have more money alright thanks
for the more money now [ __ ] y'all I've
had a better position I know dude who's
uh-uh no dude who does some coding for a
large company and he meet recently moved
to the Netherlands de neither work and
now he's working remotely you know he's
doing their their web coding and stuff
like that for them from his you know
computer setup in the Netherlands and so
he bit before he left he was like yeah
for a few months are basically just
gonna be paying me to find a new job
yeah I was like there's a hand I think
it's a Hannibal Buress Joe could do that
about how like presidential campaigning
is basically like taking several months
off your job to look for a better job
it's like it's like he likened it's like
working at subway and being like yo
subway I want you to keep paying
but I'm not gonna come to work and
instead I'm gonna canvass around the
area try to find a better job and if I
don't get that job and come back to this
job yeah like that is fine so Oh your
mom lights up oh that's great honey
they'd be crazy not to give it to you
kind of crazy mom depressed I just want
every one of these to be capper it off
with a one letter uh-huh conversation
turns to other subjects as you start
your plate you hate lying to them but
you honestly feel like your parents
don't even know you sometimes every time
on calling you add we're different name
yeah every time you see them they're
never call you by the same name and they
never look quite the same every time you
have tested the waters in the past you
come away from it feeling like you can't
get through to them like you're speaking
a different language trying to fight
through that takes so much effort and
never and never ever never takes so much
effort and never feel like it even works
and you just don't have the energy to
try it right now even though you spend
the rest of the night surrounded by your
family you feel like an alien you
retreat into your thoughts and get very
quiet for the remainder of the night as
you're leaving Malcolm takes you aside
and gives you a big hug don't let mom
get to you okay I love you kiddo oh [ __ ]
dude Malcolm loves eyes yeah by cutting
loose the expectation for mom to be
integral into our support network
Malcolm stepped up to the plate dude
Malcolm taking on X responsibilities
helping us out Malcolm's of Malcolm's
Malcolm's cool Malcolm is medication I'm
taking Malcolm all no no it's a rainy
night you're hurting through the rain to
Alex's apartment at her behest though
your pace is quick the rain is steadily
soaking up your pant legs as you
traverse the town and it's darkening
you're already poor Lou don't you just
hate them like when your thighs get
moist from walking around a little in
the rain oh yeah yeah it's got wet
thighs if you're if you're that
so it's just you're not gonna have a
good day and do come home disrobe have a
hot shower it's where i was thinking of
investing in some shrink to fit jeans
because it's like being apparently once
they shrink to fit your body they
actually have a really good look to him
but to really get them to fit you right
you have to just soak them in water then
walk around wearing them while they dry
on you wait a minute I was like this is
there when you tried this one where you
have some soaked fit jeans no I mean I
think I once tried to like I tried to
like I do that to jeans but they weren't
shrink to fit jeans specifically but
yeah but no it's like specifically like
shrink to fit jeans you you get them
soaking wet and you just walk around
wearing them yes and they dry to your
proportions it sounds unpleasant and you
have to remain like you have to maintain
a complete stasis of your physical
dimensions yeah otherwise those pants
are gonna get [ __ ] up I mean I think
they're gonna have some wiggle room then
then how are they fit to you I mean
though what I'm saying is it's like this
sounds interesting to me because it's
like holy [ __ ] like you know pants that
no matter what will look good and will
fit me but the on the flip side it's
like oh oh I'm gonna have to like walk
around for several hours just wearing
wet jeans yeah that doesn't sound fun at
all I'm gonna hate this day the call
came while you were at home after a day
of dealing with abnormally frustrating
people you'd spent the afternoon trying
to unwind and get some work on your
project done yeah we haven't talked
about our project in a while was our
project our project is like our side
creative thing having to do with what we
really want to do with our lives but we
haven't picked it up in a while oh dude
paper mache pairs Alex called an
interrupter one of your try to make
progress get frustrated at not making
progress have a harder time making
progress due to frustration repeat loops
that you haven't fully shaken off the
feelings of being annoyed with yourself
from it yet you knock on her door and on
the third not hear her voice call from
furthering the apart
to come on in as you cross the threshold
dipping dripping rain water all the way
you notice that the lights are turned
down low turn down very low in the
apartment you squint to navigate it as
you clutch on to your damp umbrella but
end up hitting your shin on a side table
mumbling a profanity under your breath
you barely make out Alex emerging from
the hallway clad and what looks to be a
robe with the bare skin of her legs
peering out underneath are we early in
noir movie dude all we need is like just
a thick layer just just a curtain of
smoke between us and Alex yeah why don't
you come in and warm up she asked she
asks in her designated slightly cheesy
quote-unquote sexy voice after a beat of
silence she states more naturally my
roommates are out of town this weekend
so I thought it might be nice to have a
little fun while they're away in every
room of that in specifically their bed
in all of their bedrooms you appreciate
her affection but you're too wrapped up
in your own negative feedback loops to
be in the mood right now what do you do
number one is crossed out let go of your
stress and be intimate with your
girlfriend to try to unwind with her
before getting physical three suggest
you do something else instead foreteller
you're not in the mood ah who would be
the best answers who would be the best
answer to two would be the most
realistic answer as to what I think
either of us would do yeah because I
mean I hate to say it but past a certain
point you actually do in my experience I
have gotten to that point where I was
just like well I feel really shitty well
this you know at the very least this is
a way to like kind of jumpstart the
brain and make it not feel so shitty
yeah just you know maybe this is what I
need to take my mind off the negative
feet
would be if I can ease into your into
your you know wavelength here yeah which
sucks because it's like passes certain
point you kind of question are you just
using your partner to medicate yourself
well yeah but but but but that's
something they brought to you in this
scenario anyway so it's like if your
drive went up and you were just like
yeah I gotta be [ __ ] all the time
like then I would say yeah but this is
more like this was her Jam you know she
invited you over in your in your you
know form fitting jeans to you know have
a night in on the town of our roommates
bedrooms Oh like so I don't know if
you're using her as Medicaid I mean you
might you might grab some added
resentment from having to perform when
you weren't you know expensing I think
in that but um I don't know I think in
this scenario it it might be okay yeah
if this becomes a habit than yeah yeah
you ever like wonder yeah well this
rural too but just I curiosity have you
ever been that position where you're
like man I wish I could actually be the
person who says I'm not in the mood and
have it just be an okay thing instead of
like you say your default response is
always like yeah sure whatever but look
at it yet to have some kind of
understanding where it's just like yeah
I'm just not feeling right now yeah it's
like it's it's I want to I want you to
have you ready yeah I want to have the
experience of saying I want to have the
experience of not being in the mood and
just rolling with that instead of like
someone new knows me better being like
oh you say you're not in the mood
something must really be wrong yeah this
must be devastating yeah it's like I'm
not in the mood oh my god did somebody
die yeah dude honey are you okay do we
need to write a eulogy huh you look at
her standing barely lit and notice
there's a few candles scattered around
the apartment
cause a fight just just haphazardly just
kind of lame they're tipped over
dripping wax everywhere it occurs to you
that she's tried to make this night
special for the two of you even though
you have a tight knot of anti-social
frustration your stomach seeing how much
she cares makes you want to try and melt
it away so you can show her how much you
care that she's gone through all this
trouble however you desperately need to
shift gears first before that's even
possible you look amazing let's have a
drink together you suggest hoping that
this will give you the push you need to
get into the mood you want in the
kitchen and pour and pour the two of you
drinks trying to focus on letting go of
your bad mood you sit down on the couch
next to her and she cuddles up to you
instantly what should we toast to she
asks as she takes her drink you think
for a moment passing up the cheesy to us
option you say what's on your mind
letting go of your bad day to tonight
the two of you cheers and you ask her
about her day conversation turns
flirtatious and the two of you find
yourselves in the bed bedroom shortly
after you find that you're having
trouble getting into things physically
with her and remember the diminished
arousal was a possible side effect of
your magic medication yeah have
you hoped that you are a part of the
population it wouldn't be affected by it
but it seems as though this was not the
case however you're able to still enjoy
the closeness with Alex and fall asleep
together happily well that's that's nice
at least yeah the verities that didn't
just spry roll you further into oh god
my life sucks yeah one and at least as
we can tell right now she's not you know
upset about it yeah alex has got a
pretty like out Alex's is pretty patient
thank each Hill she's peed oh thank god
alex is not like mom yeah thank God that
we did not we did not marry her own
mother yeah Alex but hey it's an early
winter evening you never know what could
happen it's an early winter evening and
even though it's not particularly late
the time of year has lent the sky and
almost prematurely darkened cast oh
whoops oh we don't get seasonal
affective disorder no day after day just
like today you trudge home from a job
you have increasingly come home come to
hate on this day your job misery seems
to have reached critical mass and not
even shedding your rain laden and
uncomfortable world close helps you to
unwind from your workday you collapse
into your couch blank and numb while
your job always seemed to just be an
unpleasant reality of existence it was a
position you sort of fell into
unexpectedly never intending to work
their long term and it's getting harder
and harder to keep it up well it's
certainly not your dream job you've
always just sort of stuck it out you've
always just sort of stuck it out out of
necessity before but it's becoming
increasingly difficult to do that though
you couldn't even begin to imagine what
else you could do you find yourself face
to face with a question you just can't
ignore is your complacency worth the
price of this level of misery what do
you do number one is totally crossed out
get proactive polish off your resume and
start looking for other jobs to send
feelers out to
to try and at least be productive by
focusing your efforts on your project
today number three and lessly look
through classifieds for another job for
turn on the TV and let your mind go
blank oh oh not do that even though
that's a very easy trap to fall into
yeah and this is hard because none of
them feel like none of these things
could lead you down the road to feeling
better lykia you're kind of sitting the
project could like trap you back into
the I'm trying to work on my project but
progress is so slow going I don't this
sucks i hate doing this that I've suck
oh yeah like you'll start to you you
could start to feel like you're shitty
and start piling things on yourself yeah
I could never work on this I never have
time my stupid job yeah number three is
aimlessly look through the classes like
then it's like oh I'm so under qualified
I would never get this job i don't have
the credentials I don't have the resume
whatever i don't have the references and
then number fours i just spent a whole
[ __ ] night just watching TV doing
nothing i'm a useless lump yeah i mean i
feel like three could easily turn into
four cuz three like that it seems like
the best possible turn out in this
circumstance for three is basically you
just kind of peru's and go you know it's
like even at best it wouldn't be
particularly bad you probably just would
be kind of like I uninspired and then go
watch TV yeah so I think the project is
our best bet that's the best idea yeah
number two you know cuz the project at
the very least is based in something we
like to do yeah but is you know that's
at least from my own personal experience
it's hard especially when you got
something bugging at you because like
your projects then you feel guilty for
for working on your own thing when
they're like outstanding and I've I
recently had an experienced worse like i
looked i have my own project and i
looked at my own project and I I my
project started off as something that I
did for school
a while back I wanted to revise and make
good and so I looked back at an old
draft of it with you know notes and and
versions are notes and suggestions from
my professor and I looked at it and I
was like oh this is so not where I would
go with this now and then I saw the
notes of like suggestions for you know
pointing out things that didn't quite
work and suggestions for how to move
forward and it actually got me thinking
oh my god yeah I'm totally on the same
page as my professor was then so I'm
seeing these issues and I'm coming up
with solutions and it gave me an idea
for how to fix some of it so I was like
I it felt like very yeah i saw the file
that had the notes on it and I was like
oh my god this is I was on that cusp of
I could either look at this and there
could be something valuable in it in
this early draft with these notes or I
could look at this and this could like
Shen send me into a downward spiral that
makes me hate the project and not start
doing anything on it hmm it actually
turned out for the better like I looked
at analyst like oh wow there's actually
getting my gears turning again I wrote
some new notes and jotted down some new
brainstorming stuff for it and it was
kind of at you know edifying huh so what
good let's see how this works for us all
right kiddos we got to take a brief
break you know potty food you know
replenish you know rebuild our
psychological muster maybe call Alex
maybe khalix maybe call mom except each
she doesn't get it just get it yeah well
now colones maybe he'll know it's him
all right and we will see you in part
four of dank pression a West Russian
quest the quest for Curly's gold gold
quest for four curlies prescription
paper for those medicines that would
help to balance this
there